alors que la rentrée scolaire les élèves
arrivent progressivement je ferai demain
vendredi c'est notre première au niveau
c'est toujours un moment où on est très
préoccupé au métro journée pédagogique
mais on s'ennuie pas une réunion pour
penser à genac lance tout la rentrée
scolaire qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
les élèves comment vous les écrire qui
se sent bien créer un premier consul
la première impression est tellement
important même si tout ce jeu par
moments mais je pense que c'est
important d'y accueillir ce sens bien
sûr tous les élèves de première
secondaire ces nouveaux prix s'occuper
de sa santé
belani